well I mentioned it because it's sort of
an extreme diet as opposed to say the
South Beach or other types of dinah
don't like the internet names of these
things so much but the low glycemic
index high protein diets Adkins is a
initially a pure protein diet no carbs
protein and fats it's actually been
studying it's not as unhealthy as you
might think as it sounds like for short
periods of time it actually is
counterintuitive that it can lower your
cholesterol in some ways but long term
most people can't stay on that you can't
stay it's not healthy ultimately to stay
on a very high protein very high fat no
carbohydrate diet which is what Adkins
is I mentioned it is a prototypical high
protein diet but ultimately you have to
transition off most of these diets that
are radical to something else you can
lose weight on the cabbage soup diet but
you can't stay on that for life and the
problem is you got to live it not just
diet it and you have to have that
transition plan and the problem with
that consists when you put carbs back in
that same problem exists but if you do
it carefully low glycemic carbs balance
it in with the fats and the proteins you
end up on something that's similar to
some of these other middle-of-the-road
diets low glycemic index relatively high
protein careful fat intake and that's
really really gonna be
well that's what we're talking about a
bit is low carbohydrate low glycemic
index carbohydrates and those are the
healthier ones they're the ones that get
digested more slowly they tend to be
less processed so pastas white breads
things like that are the bad carbs if
you will as opposed to whole grains you
know interestingly processed oats get
digested very rapidly and a high
glycemic index but steel-cut oats which
are whole oats that have to be cooked
those get digested much more slowly and
our low glycemic index food so it really
sometimes how the foods even prepared
wild rice instead of white rice I
mentioned whole grains sweet potatoes
instead of white potatoes those types of
things it's hard to go into it
completely also some research has shown
that high volumes of food tend to make
people fill up more quickly even though
there's less calories now it may not
work ultimately if you don't get in the
proper amount of calories or intake to
make you comfortable but you know you
can fill up a plate with lettuce and and
you know sort of very large volume low
calorie foods and eat that and feel full
versus a very small amount of a high
calorie dense food where you might eat
it and not feel as full so managing your
fullness and your hunger is an important
part of dying